as long as it takes to get whoever i'm
talking with to express themselves in
every angle around the story this
because I'm an editor by trade and
originally started editing so I'm always
thinking about all the connecting pieces
that I would need for the story so
there's there's I usually keep a pad and
pen I never ever try to look down when
they were talking to me this is a docu
university right so I'm going to give
all my little tips and and then then
basically I attempt to make it a
conversation it's not an interview it's
really I reveal as much about myself as
is appropriate as comes up naturally
it's a you know let them feel your
humanity let them feel that you're not
judging them and then at the end of the
interview realize what your agenda was
what the story is that you're telling
and really try and hone in on those
sound bites that you're going to need
for the edit especially if you're in a
faraway place and this is your one shot
you've thought of lines that you need
out of this person you've thought of
lines that you need in general for the
story and maybe those you can plug the
person into those you know they could be
the person that says that line and
literally feed it to I'm going to sort
like what I hear you saying is did you
say some do you mean kind of like this
you know it wiped them into and they say
that's all right men how about could you
tell me that cuz my voice is going to be
in this phone you know you do that kind
of thing when you're desperate movies
that i may have both been historical
recent history historical but they've
been historical films and so there's a
different agenda with a historical film
in there is with an investigative
filmers
yeah so the approach of a director is
different in that regard but I from me
I'm really I love talking heads I really
hate that the idea of talking heads is
considered to be a pejorative and for me
the characters of what makes the movie
so I really try to build a bond with
these people as characters yeah i think
i think the bond is what's really
important audios interested in feeding
the lines it's really never worked for
me I mean how do you do what the exact I
think to get that what I do is I get
them to express in their own words
whatever it is I asked him a question no
I talk about something but then when I
get to like we live in public for
example um josh harris very much had his
own way of expressing things but it was
not good for voiceover and I needed him
to talk about his mother abandoning him
when he was young so we wove around and
went around and went around and it was
never something I knew I could use the
Edit to the point where I was like
here's kind of what I was thinking as
from spending time at this footage that
you were feeling am i close with this
you know is this a good diagnosis of
what you were feeling and then he said
yeah that's pretty much true as what
would you say that actually I mean it's
like it's like a police officer getting
a confession
yeah that's not actually never work for
me but I'm going to keep trying it oh
but one thing on those wines started in
the opposite direction is if you I find
sometimes if you want somebody to say
something with real passion you say the
opposite of what you know they believe
and it go no not at all and they come
back are so blunt I and I'm going to
show clip from this film but you're not
going to see this part but one time I I
was dealing with a cult leader and I'm
new and I had spent a couple weeks at a
treatment center with the people who
were in the cult and I had met him yet
and suddenly I met these dinners and you
know at his house and I'm trying to get
him to talk about what he's done to
these children and I could not figure
out how at every session I left there
and I call my mom and say if I don't
call you in three hours call the police
I was sure they're going to joe's my
food or whatever and I would go through
these such thing I get great stuff about
the Bible whatever but I would never get
that so finally I just said do you have
any advice for me i cannot get my
two-year-old to behave I just don't know
what and he said Debra go get the fly
swatter and he had his wife go I get the
flies for already said hold out your
hand you know oh no you said whack my
hand and I whacked his hand and he said
I can't even feel that do it again you
know it was like amazing he acted it out
so that that kind of thing like asking
advice is another way or coming against
or sometimes directly confronting them
Frank foundation probably send into film
I said I understand that you hit them
with a rod anyway yeah I mean it's just
brilliant you know they got a few
spankings you know but ok so let's back
up for a sec so a poor Michelle yours
going to be the first clip so you guys
can queue up aunties quickly so to you
guys pre-interview like I find myself
I'm co-directing a doc right now and
what we have opposite inclinations
towards pre interviewing meeting
you know talking to them ahead of time
getting your story at a time one of us
really likes to pre-interview the other
one doesn't ever want to pre-interview
so we're trying to find that balance I'm
curious each of you how you deal with
that I I mean the stuff that I've done I
felt very very very strongly against pre
interviewing it actually is interesting
because what I've done q and A's with
the people in my cast at screening
they've often told this story that one
side asked them if they would be in the
film when the subject matter would come
up with it because I didn't want any of
it to be not fresh and with we were here
which is the current movie I was able to
interview without having done any I mean
it you'll see it came very much for my
own personal experience in San Francisco
but with the kets I had an enormous
amount of material available that gave
me the ability to go into the interviews
never having discussed any of that
information with these people and I knew
a lot I mean I know their whole sex
lives from other people's stories and so
the freshness to me is crucial to have
on camera I think the pre interviewing
really kills the freshness well I'm yes
yes no I mean I think it depends on who
it is I'm over yeah well it depends on
who do some people can say the same
thing over and over incredibly well and
so it's good to know everything that
they can say that's not I'm just 21 on a
four people it's also good to have like
a producer or something do it as well I
mean it really depends if I mean
something I find when you're getting
very sort of extensive stories from
people when you do an interview I mean
you go down this road in that room that
run it you inevitably leave some you
know past you know untrodden or whatever
and so so it's I think it's good to have
some of that information advanced as you
can
I mean it's ideal if if you have if
you're in your situation and you just
have all this knowledge to not have that
interaction but sometimes it's really a
one-shot deal and you kind of don't have
the budget to come back or this person
is going to make one hour or this
person's a congressman they're going to
make 20 minutes for you and you better
know what you're going for us but if it
can be not you who does it but a
researcher or producer or something so
that when you come in there it's fresh
and they're telling you the information
for the first time and then you kind of
have the best of both worlds and I think
there's this trust issue you know for me
sometimes pre interviewing is about
establishing a trust and then I can have
not having them actually y'all stop them
in a story okay don't go any farther
save that for the camera you know but
that kind of there's no or poor
trying to create a report a bond with
people i think my producer exaggerated
or something but she did an excellent
job so she really pulled it off both
well anyway um we're going to do that
lena like the heart to get in turnovers
but but how do you establish trust it is
the military didn't trust you right you
know I come in their short dress for the
occasion I mean they want you know these
I mean anybody coming at team of that
situation is the sort of you know doing
PR so they want they actually are
reaching out to you in a lot of ways and
that's the problem is how you get
through that they never trusted us I
mean I think if one person for us to us
did you crap in no I didn't really want
that person I mean I was hoping I you
know if they trust you you're already
it's already easier to crime everybody
else was just like this and then we had
other ways to get through unhandy so how
do you earn trust people that I trust
you well within the case of the man
you're about to see what I did was just
tell and this is where manipulation does
come in at me too quite honestly I he'd
written a book called revelation
simplified where he was simplifying the
Book of Revelations and in so doing
distorting the text
and I met with a Harvard professor
dissected it all that good he saw me he
actually said to me I see you as God
sent you because I I said I'm
interviewing a bunch of pastors through
the south and I had interviewed other
pastors but where I sort of was telling
an untruth as it were was that it was
really not all about you know Book of
Revelations and that's how I first got
to meet him I couldn't say I've just
spent two weeks at a cult treatment
center with all of your congregants
hearing about your vicious crimes you
know would you care to comment you know
there's no way and I had no film without
him and i also thought he would come off
as a total monster if i didn't put his
point of view in and if i put his point
of view and from the defensive up front
he would I wouldn't be of doing justice
to him so this is how i justified my
untruth but i'm with this pretty good
justification and so I just said you
know what can we talk about the book of
revelations and I talked about what is
interesting to that person whatever it
is so I usually start out by having a
person talk about themselves or what
they're most passionate about whatever
whether that's what I want them to talk
about the end or not and that really
gets against things flowing you know and
allows them to feel respected and that
they're expressing their point of view I
mean I've even been pulled over before
you know and just ask the police officer
her point of view and like she asked me
to turn off the camera i said well i
believe it's my right to leave it on she
said turn that off right now and i said
well i actually could you show me in a
book of law because i believe it's my
right to keep it on and she said I said
turn off ice actually I'm out here as a
documentary filmmaker filming this event
i'm wondering why you're pulling people
over there's kids dying out there as
soon as she was off to the races talking
about why she was stopping this whole
thing she said you have a nice day I'm
just like let me go so it's the power of
the camera of just kind of people want
to express themselves was empathy we
talked about talked about this with yeah
I'm actually L made mother already right
but I remember interviewing how measles
once and I said what's the most
important quality for documentary
filmmaker who said empathy I mean no
surprise he was a psychologist but it is
empathy we have to establish that
empathy with our subjects it was the
crossover but from their point of view
to his and it was just a really
interesting time we literally did follow
them home and it was amazing how it
turned to darkness and it turned to
lightning as we got to South Carolina it
all truly happened that way um and I'm
always just so moved by Paris a
nine-year-old having to deal with your
mother attempting suicide and then
spending her you know yoyo around saying
I'm just worried you know we carrying
that weight of her mother potentially
dying by her own hand at any time and
then it's just amazing that the first
moment and it's funny is first moments
you talk about pre-interviews first
moments are so important and I suggest
you always roll on your first moment you
know and sometimes you forget because
you're nervous but first time you're
going to meet a character roll just roll
your camera because you never know I've
used it I don't think I've met josh
harris on camera but I met Anton of
beginning a dig on camera here I meet
Raymond on camera you threatens to whip
me actually
what what I think I think some
remarkable about one of many things on
do about your films is that the
interviews never feel like interviews
you know their their master their fly on
the wall I mean I did there some in
there was a lady sitting in a hotel room
or she's one of the deep growl at david
i like i love it a good talking head but
here's the matchup like like targeted
just like yours don't feel like talking
heads I think it's just in the moment
you know if you catch somebody and
actually the moment and in you it's when
you step into a scene when you hang back
so you never it's a feeling kind of
thing I mean I could say something as
scary as burner said and said you know
you're either just bored to do this or
not but I mean I don't think that's it i
think it's just like you get it sent
after a time of doing this of hanging
back and letting the action happen but i
remember being like 22 years old 21 and
getting a position on a documentary that
was going to be about rodeo girls and i
remember being really frustrated the cut
the directors of the film were a couple
and i guess they were having discord
they ended up breaking up but that
nonetheless and i don't know if it
would've been different otherwise they
never ever interacted with the subjects
they hang back and ferret a but you
can't do that i mean i can't do that i
ain't been able to figure out how to
keep their i do very veil photography
feels like I've always apply the law but
I also interact but that's the trick is
Nemo into interacting window and one
yeah there's those spaces in between in
life and we all have them where you can
jump in where you've just gotten off the
phone the car you're walking into your
house and you haven't yet reached the
your child with a fridge you know I mean
that period of time if I'm rolling
camera I'm going to ask you about the
phone call or what you're feeling about
what's going to happen next and in that
moment I'm going to get a much more
fluid response perhaps then a different
response and in the moment response then
I will two weeks from them when you can
look back on it yeah in the moment
responses yeah unfolding I mean I feel
like most exciting i was unfold over
time that's why people go to the movies
to watch scripted films that's what we
can do we felt if we follow the things
that really kind of interesting places
to interview people he's in a car when
the driving because they're sort of semi
in his own or semi distracted and
somehow the the interview some is much
more casual than if you are even though
it's almost the same setup right except
for the driving as opposed to asking the
same questions in in a chair or
something like that sunny journey and
their own journey to write me there's
always things to react you know interact
with it better you can even kind of way
to or it can suddenly change the subject
and interesting money there is some but
there's almost no music at all during
the interviews and I was also really
determined to meet people on screen and
to allow their process to play out in
real time rather than to you know as is
more conventionally done to cut it end
it was really about not only maintaining
a sense of authenticity for the audience
but allowing the audience in some way to
share a real-time emotional experience
with the people in screen but this was
an interesting went to look at I'd never
really thought about how long this one
goes on so to two out of two
mention students at MIT hopefully
there's no suicide you in your club just
the idea of telling even narrowing the
story down to San Francisco to tell a 30
year history of aids in San Francisco
was such a kind of a daunting thing and
I didn't know how many people I would
have in the film I didn't know how it
would approach it and it happened very
organically and I realized now that my
intuitions were very strong about what I
did and didn't want to do even if I
couldn't have articulated it but all the
people who were in the film are people
who I did know a little and just
happened to run into the only there's
only one person who I knew in advance
that i was going to interview and it's
because i knew his history and i thought
he would be a good experiment to see how
this process would play out but Daniel I
ran into it a demonstration of known him
for if early for many many years and in
the course of talking to him I thought
hmm you know Daniel would be great for
this and part of the casting was in the
process of asking people if they were
interested in realizing through their
response whether they got the value of
doing it not only for the audience which
all of them had a sense of that but also
for their own process of catharsis so
all everybody in the film is someone who
I happen to bump into somewhere along
the line and say oh you want to be the
movie I only what I thought initially
that I'd have to do about 30 or 40
interviews for the film and then maybe
pick 12 and I only wound up doing nine
and there's five in the film I mean it's
kind of mind-boggling that what about
and decry was that he would be telling
his story and he looked at me and Marsha
Loretta lead off of tears pouring down
her faces and it gave him the
encouragement so I think the empathy
piece was unique on this project simply
because this the story being told is
exactly the period that I lived in San
Francisco so they knew that where I was
coming from was not a you know an
external thing so it was a very it was
like it was like 25 years of therapy for
both people wrapped into a three hour
interview so it was very intense I
actually had my producer Amy ziering do
a lot of the interviews
women because of the women were raped in
the military and one of the challenges
actually is because in particular in
cases where it was relatively recent
although with something like that it
never goes away but is that is actually
to keep them from crying early on
because once they break their in a
totally different state it can be hard
to cut and there's a lot of information
you always kind of want to when you're
cutting home to break as you know you
want to write kind of getting closer and
closer and closer but if you want to
hold back our way and and if it's a
right to assume then the whole interview
goes in this other kind of state and it
can be much can be harder to use so it's
it's something when you're interviewing
somebody you see it's going toward a
sense of direction you know oftentimes I
would try to actually pull back and and
then you know start talking about other
things then slowly come back at it again
of the event or whatever it was really
traumatic for them then committee is
Joan Greg's and I think she'd only given
a very few number of interviews and
mostly should have very sort of friendly
frayed kind of papers and so we couldn't
get an interview with her and we really
wanted it and so basically the only
opportunity I had was to once i
submitted my film a for training then
she was sort of obligated to call me
back and discuss the rating of me so in
California you can't you can't record
somebody's voice without their
permission which is why I'm here to the
New York are less you know Las Vegas is
much easier places
something like there's actually about
you know 38 states that's the one way
typing States and if you're in one of
those states you're very lucky um but
anyway so we what we did is we you know
that we actually the first the first
interview she called me three times the
first time she did agree to be taken
after that she I think she got kind of
wise but we ended up using animation in
sort of writing notes and basically in
this case having our Associate Producer
who is also a voice-over artist renew
her voice so that also gives you a
chance to you know redo the interview if
you will do stuff from the filmmaker to
not just the observer to being the
participant observer and did you plan
that from the beginning or did the
absence of the interview is you know
make that happen yeah I some degree I
plan that from the beginning I was
following my process I mean I was doing
interviews of course but then I knew
that I was going to submit the film that
i made and part of that actually was
falling around a p.i and my producer was
actually shooting a lot of this stuff
like this he was shooting this and so I
would I became a subject I mean you know
I'm sort of pretty natural he was
affected this you know this nuclear
family this his mother or his his
communities in his relationship to his
church and this in this case it's a
scene where he has a discussion with his
mother and initially was set up as an
interview for to the two of them and I
was able to transform it into more of a
kind of a very tasty and I'll explain
to resume because I actually obey the
time limits of you know I actually cut
it down so was it kind of a cut-down
scene so it might seem a little little
bit choppy you know there was something
that obviously was unspoken that they
still had to work out between them so if
you this obviously works with two or
three people and what you do is you you
know you sit down and you know it's not
you know sort of informal interview
you're just you know it again was my
producer shooting this and you just
start talking and asking questions and
you get to sort of what the sensitive
point is between them and then you start
a univ NT well you start asking them
these bitties questions and then when
they look back at you you look down and
then thank you sort of will naturally
look to the person they're with and
again if they come back to you just say
well can you say that to Tony or you say
that your mom and you just kind of keep
going I mean this was over about an hour
and a half period and you just kind of
keep going at the same issue and going
at the same issue and then of course you
get your coverage in and probably
seventy five percent of the scene was
what was spoken to the camera but there
was enough that about twenty five
percent that gave you an opportunity to
cut it as a verte seen as if you were
there in this discussion which you know
sort of did happen many times but never
happened with this intensity finally now
so it really it's a verte scene that
sort of set up finding I want
facilitating a conversation right
exactly exactly honey you must do that a
lot oh yeah all the time I mean that you
you just say I'm not here as what I do
so I'm really not here I'm just not
eager I just can do thin that doesn't
mean that what they did is say they try
to work with me on that I might write
you know it's really trying to talk to
each other I'm not here and then I throw
and I do this actually in something i'm
shooting currently i do this all the
time it's like a it's like web it's a
you know a tech startup and they're
always having these interactions and i
want them to have interactions amongst
themselves but i want to make sure
certain topics are discussed and so I
throw in the world they're used to me
now and they'll work with it they'll run
with that topic next topic you know and
so I'm sort of directing the
conversation but not not in it and then
sometimes if they do break it and they
look right
the cameras because they've become
emotional or sure they're they're
calling the judgment of the camera you
know and that's interesting too so but
with join us we had to do that a lot
where we had in South Carolina we were
recording phone calls all the time it
was awesome and we would have them get
together and we would have them get
together the two to call to make a phone
call to each other because one of the
characters live kind of far away Tanya
who was the one who's struggling the
most and it was in crowd where we have
them called the lawyer together and then
do the boxes you know would they all be
in their own little place we'd have like
four cameras wherever they were and you
can have a lot of I don't know it's just
it's just interesting as a filmmaker
it's it's totally a lie to say that
you're not a part of it because you are
you're making a film therefore
everything's changed now understand the
emotional truth of life right
theoretically few green the MDA oh I
guess it's not the emotional truth
phonetic the system I want to break down
says whatever we want to do we want to
kind of open it up right and so
sometimes when we want to add the viewer
feel like they are directly interacting
with it so that it's not a passive
experience dealing with the questions
that you have in dealing with the
outline and dealing with the subject
matter that you know that you need and
the other side of it which is really
allowing the spontaneity of the moments
to present information in ways that
happen organically and you have to do
both of those and I think
my first film on the cat's eye i had my
co-director with me and he had a big
outline of boo he had a big outline of
information that we knew that we needed
and I would follow a much more organic
process and then you know we'd break
every 15 minutes and he would sort of
say we'll try to get to this trying to
get to that on this movie it was very
different at really really loud for the
organic process to take place partially
because I know it was therapeutic I knew
that on some level I own it to the
person who was in the room to talk about
whatever they needed to talk about and
it was not my place to direct the
interview too much and so it was very
natural the process and to some degree
you know I certainly was very aware of
editing I certainly was very aware of
what information I wanted but I wasn't
necessarily sure which information would
come from which person and I also knew
that the finished movie with to some
degree be determined by what came up in
the interviews that I couldn't entirely
control so it's very different I think
when you're doing a history interview
and I really like I mean I've been
interviewed a lot also I mean I think
all of us have been interviewed and i
really like when I feel like an
interviewer is not coming from just
questions but when someone is actually
having an organic moment and responding
it's like in a personal conversation
when you're having dinner with something
you want to know that someone's
listening to you and that they're going
to ask you a question not and based on
what they cursed but based on what you
just said and they'll go oh well that's
interesting and then it goes places that
you don't necessarily expect absolutely
i'm sure i'm not misunderstood though i
don't i don't ever come at it like that
with an agenda like that it's more of
its always a dialogue it's always a
conversation and that's what i think
when i see new a new field producer or a
new documentary director trying to do an
interview that's like mistake number one
is I have my ten questions and whatever
that person says I'm moving on to number
three now you know
that just kills it you know it's all
about whatever that person wants to talk
about but you wind you also have certain
things that you need to get to places
you need to get to and you'll get there
but it never happens in the order you
plan right whoa that's our King that's
it I wouldn't think I'd love an open
diplomatic public is josh's talking
about this kind of giving a forecast of
how the internet seemed so cool how
absolutely w insidious it is and it
starts on this tight shot of him on a
computer looks like a Skype interview
and it pulls out suddenly he's on 25
screens and 25 computers I mean that's a
brilliant use of imagery with in an
interview that was in coming from the
Republic it was an eight-month edit and
5,000 hours of footage and during that
time I was really just editing the film
but I always had the opening I never
didn't have the opening and graphics guy
the poor poor graphics guy had to work
the whole eight months on that opening
too because he was like mine what are
you talking about you know just there's
two main titles of flash on the screen
because I love both these if you want to
both like they want to look at different
it was just the idea that he was saying
goodbye to his mother over a video
camera and that was a whole point of how
disconnected he was probably real human
emotion because of Technology and then
that turns into his prediction of the
internet as it does he becomes its he
clearly shared too much and now he's on
youtube with his you know his private
moment is now is now out there for
everybody and then yeah it's all about
the screens and the virtual box as we
put our sources so the whole movie is
actually your honor to see past the
first
and what I found worked in several
interviews was to take the point where I
knew they were the weakest and just kind
of go at it go away from it come back go
away and they were getting more and they
were getting more and more frustrating
it was like they kept wanting to they
could say the same thing over and over
me something once we're really good did
but some of them and they started trying
to answer in different ways and that's
you know once you start doing that we
don't we think of an interview you know
just give up think you're gonna lose
your physical office work um well it was
a quite pissed yeah I was that it was a
little bit you go just right to the edge
you know it was you know my way on this
person that they hear what I just said
right right you know so um so that that
seemed to work the other thing I was
just think about interviews in Manion is
and I noticed this when i attended
myself i love it when people just
completely change the subject i mean go
in a completely different direction and
it's i'm always when i'm giving what i'm
doing these interviews and you know you
you think well maybe this is going
exactly where i want where how and when
can i come in from a totally different
direction that will completely surprised
them I mean and it's a very delicate
complex thing to figure out when you
want to do that because we go if you do
at the wrong time they just kind of look
at you bye but if you hit them at the
right time there's someone expected that
they suddenly just kind of go into that
kind of opening but you can't throw them
off balance too much you can yeah i mean
i can't seem like sort of you know
plotted or
you know any kind of got you in any way
but it's just like oh you know just up
on the subject it's like you know
changing the topic here comes you should
be interviewed by you know we go just
junior view we can all play
you